a sad story though to get things started
one of those stunners that came out of
the blue yesterday afternoon just before
we started pftpm
vincent jackson a great receiver second
round pick in 2005 spent time with the
chargers and then the final five seasons
of his career with the buccaneers found
dead at the age of 38 in a hotel in
florida no signs of trauma
investigation on going as to the cause
of death just an absolute
stunner
shireen uh
i i i uh
i it's it i was 38 years old and
miles simmons and i were talking about
this yesterday i mean death is all
around us with the pandemic and
everything else but
it's impossible to get used to it and i
think we get to a point where we just
brace
for whatever's next because it seems
like there's always something else
that's coming around the corner that
that's just gonna smack us in the face
and uh vincent jackson the latest
example of that
and i think when you see the 38 mike
that's what really hit you this guy was
so young and had so much of his life yet
left and uh it's unfortunate whatever
happened to vincent jackson but it is a
stunner whenever you see somebody this
young
die at that age it's just it's
incredible and uh you know i think most
people
even this generation remembers vincent
jackson and what he did with the
chargers in the box and just an
outstanding receiver for a long time
took a little bit to get going in his
career but boy once he did mike
three-time pro bowler and he was really
a good player a really really good
player and you just see by the
outpouring from everybody in the
community how much he meant especially
that tampa bay community uh to mike and
how much good he had done in his life
which i said i think speaks more to the
person
uh than than what what you do on field
that you're going to be remembered by
and i think it says a lot about vincent
jackson that that's what people are
remembering him by today
every team has one nominee per year for
the nfl walter payton man of the year
award vincent jackson arrived in tampa
bay in 2012.
each of the four seasons after that that
he was with the team 13 14 15 16 he was
the nominee think of how quickly you
establish your presence from a
charitable standpoint
first year there yeah it's your first
year there you're not gonna you're not
gonna do so much your first year there
that you're the walter payton nfl man of
the year nominee but each of the next
four
that was the individual who received
that designation from the buccaneers
organization and the buccaneers
issued a statement yesterday as well
regarding the passing of vincent jackson
and there was a flood of tweets from
various teammates executives etc who had
been with vincent jackson it really
wasn't all that long ago he's remember
this buccaneers team i remember mike
evans was drafted in 2014
between evans and jackson one of the top
receiving duos in the nfl shereen right
out of the gates
it was and you saw you know mike evans
tweet and i honestly for a second forgot
that they had played together because it
doesn't seem like mike evans is that far
into his career
and then you start going back you're
like boy you know evans has played for a
while i played i mean he didn't
officially retire till 2018. it was a
couple years before that they last
played but you know this is a guy who
you truly remember of how good he was on
the field i go back mike to the 2007
playoffs when he was with the chargers
that was the chargers best chance with
philip rivers to go to the super bowl
and it's unfortunate that ladainian
thomason got hurt in the postseason but
vincent jackson and those three playoff
games that year he carried them more
than than the banged up lt did he hit
114 yards and a touchdown in the first
playoff game against tennessee the next
week against indianapolis seven catches
for 93 yards and a touchdown they came
back he kept him in the game against new
england then if the afc championship
game he had six catches for 93 yards and
and you have that memory of lt standing
over there on the sidelines injured with
the park on and the hoodie over his head
and vincent jackson was doing everything
he could to try to make up for the loss
of lt and we just was outstanding in
that postseason and i i do remember that
run i covered a couple of those games
and vincent jackson was incredible that
year in that playoff run
and you think back to 2014 what they had
at the skill position specifically
receiver in tight end the buccaneers had
mike evans first round pick six foot
five vincent jackson six foot five tight
end austin safari and jenkins who never
really worked out but there was a ton of
promise there six foot five and the
quarterback mike lennon was six foot
seven they had some very tall guys in
that window of time now obviously jameis
winston came along in 2015 as a first
overall pick in the draft but i i
remember now and and you know the years
go by so quickly with the nfl and every
team seems to have a completely
different makeup year in and year out
but
it kind of comes back to you as you
remember it and think through it that
they they had those three really big
targets going into 2014 and vincent
jackson still had plenty of gas in the
tank still and and was a great mentor
for a guy like a mike evans and it just
wasn't that long ago
that jackson was playing and playing at
a high level in the nfl and we extend
our condolences obviously to the family
friends teammates it it just it just is
another tragedy in the broader nfl
community
and uh there's tragedies all around us
that it just everywhere you turn whether
it's nfl or beyond the nfl and we're
just trying to get through life one day
at a time as we we await the broader
cloud of
of the pandemic to go away it just it
just has just been
a strange time as strange a time as i
can ever remember and and situations
like this just kind of underscore how
strange these times are
and you think about mike all the people
we've lost over the last couple weeks
with marty schottenheimer and you go
back to therese
paler who worked for the kansas city
star and most recently with yahoo sports
and he was in his 30s went to sleep and
didn't wake up and and now we have
another guy in his 30s that was
significant to the nfl now
who's also gone and it's just been a sad
uh couple weeks since the super bowl
ended that that we've had some of these
deaths mike and and hopefully this is
the last one let's don't have any more
of these i i hate starting a show like
this because it's such a downer um but
but it's nice to remember vincent
jackson and all the great things he did
on and off the field
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports